I picture him watching reer Madness and
having to pause it to enter the door oh
my God yeah yeah yeah
around hey gang this holiday season you
might be looking for nutritious
convenient meals to keep you energized
on jam-packed days Factor America's
number one ready to eat meal delivery
service can help you fuel up fast for
breakfast lunch and dinner with Chef
prepared they're so good dietitian
approved ready to eat meals delivered
straight to your door head toctor
meals.com
dp50 and use code code dp50 to get 50%
off that's code
dp50 factor meals.com
dp50 to get 50% off want to say thank
you so much to our sponsor Skylight
calendar the Skylight calendar is super
easy to set up and use it works by
syncing events from already existing
calendars you have including Google
Outlook and apple calendars you can also
add events directly using the touchcreen
or with the free Skylight mobile app as
a special limited time offer to our
listeners you can get $15 off your
purchase of a skylight calendar when you
go to Skylight cal.com
DPT to get $15 off your purchase of a
skylight calendar just go to Skylight
Cal that is uh SK y l i g HT cal.com
DPT hey townies welcome to another
episode of Dum people Town population
you population [__] Dan another Dan in
the house we're not this isn't this is
like a Time suck dumb people Town Mash
sometimes we talk about like things we
get into like theories and there are
conspiracies and all sorts of wonderful
Dan two scars the conspir two Dan and
two scars Daniel and Dan Dan and Daniel
ran and Jay uh the world is getting
Dumber we know that we know that is
happening do you feel that do you sense
that in all of your sort of winding
through the labyrinths of this world
that like we are suddenly getting Dumber
I uh just saw the turn like I don't know
three or four years ago where it's like
I've tried to debunk conspiracies right
the whole time with time suck and
everybody was on board like the first
couple years like oh those are silly
those that's ridiculous that's crazy
that people would believe that and I
remember when qinon came around and when
it first came around I I didn't even do
a full episode on it I did like a little
patreon mini thing because I was like
this is so stupid there's not even
enough to talk about for an hour and a
half
and then when that went mainstream and I
started seeing bumper stickers and I'm
like it is preposterously idiotic so has
your we'll we'll talk about the podast
we'll now it's political too I know
that's czy right so now everything is
having a stance on crazy conspiracy
stuff oh you're woke means that you put
an ad crazy it's always that people I
always try to tell people the absence of
information is not information right
right like that so many can hinge hinge
on that well how come you never see any
because they don't exist that's why you
don't
cuz otherwise you can say the absence of
information could provide you to believe
anything not there so it must be right
that must be how it is like no that
Daniel if someone says well what about
I'm like this discussion's over we're
finished I think about aam's Razer that
philosophic it's like there's two
possibilities and one requires millions
of people to keep a secret and aliens
and a hollow Earth and just completely
throwing science on its head and the
other one is like the simplest thing
simp thing probably that thing it's most
definitely that yeah it's it's too much
effort and energy to keep something like
quiet like that you don't think one
person's going to leak you don't think
one person is going to say something
also I think sometimes it has to do with
like uh the inability to process what
the truth must be though like I think a
lot of times people have a hard time
with uh 9911 because they they would
then have to accept how susceptible we
are to being and attack so they go it
must be like some a comic had a great
joke where they were like America's so
crazy that like we even wanted to take
there's some Americans even wanted to
take credit for doing that to ourselves
that like that like the terrorists were
like all right we got them and they know
that we can get them whenever we want oh
no what yeah they like wait what no
they're saying there's a lot of them
saying they did it to themselves that we
actually didn't do it they're like what
no we did it no we got it like no they
actually believe they did trolling the
terrorists all right let's jump into
Inside Story J let's get into dumb Minds
Dum is always an inside job I have a bad
one I have Story one is I hate the
person in this I cannot wait I hate how
I've dumb dumb things happened and then
I just hate how the quotequote victim I
can't wait okay uh s up by Adam pton at
psky 75 it unwanted side of marijuana
found in food delivery okay side side of
marijuana I got a cheeseburger and a
suddenly a side of marijuana sweet
Columbus Ohio was just there on tour mhm
a Columbus man found marijuana at the
bottom of a bag of food he ordered to be
delivered yeah so obviously not what he
wanted no you should not order from door
has hey hey we can probably end the
episode right
there that
is everybody have a good night those are
our plugs thank
you the man asked to remain anonymous
but said he ordered the food through
door Dash no I just guessed do you guys
Dash do you door Dash uh I've done it a
couple I for some reason I have a I have
a like a emotional adversity to all of
it I don't I want to go get my own food
I like getting I like picking it up I
like yeah I like just go I don't know
and I also feel like it's going to be
not like weed at the bottom of your bag
ruined or it's going to be wrong or it's
going to be cold I know people who will
door Dash like ice cream yeah and I'm
like you are crazy I mean that's how
much that that's like that you're doing
it because you're like I want the
convenience you're in your pajamas
you're like I don't want to put clothes
on and go so we've done it my my wife
has done it when like I'm not in town
and she doesn't she justes want to like
take kid out to a store to come back
door Dash that's single parents it's a
godsend my wife will do it just because
she will literally spend half of what
she would spend if she went to the store
she's very much like a shiny object oh
that's cool oh that's cool oh that's
like
you've made it a finite number of things
that can come that's it there's no
emotion with it it's not like the oh I'd
like to have that oh I didn't know that
thing existed you just takes the emotion
out shopping why aren't we doing that
ankle all right so your that okay also
I'll just say my favorite salad place
it's one of those like conveyor belt
deals like you or you know assembly line
deals um also like Chipotle if you if
you're not there ordering it in front of
them you are going to
get it's just going to be barely any
chicken you know what I mean like you
need someone watching the person Daniel
likes to be the one who's like uh yeah
you know you can go crazy with the
chicken yeah
chicken the guac you can go you can go
nuts with the guac like it's just I'm
not going to stop you I was scared at
first but then again I wasn't very
surprised said the man who ordered his
dinner from D Das why wouldn't you be
surprised and what are you scared of
flush will I die if I touch this weed
I'm going to get so high I won't be able
to know who I am getting a contact high
he snapped the photo where he found a
fork and a bag filled with marijuana
okay it's just weed in in a plastic bag
though right kind of looks like Chipotle
paper bag I think I pictur him watching
reer Madness and having to pause it to
enter the door oh my god well that's
when you like you know how like we all
in this to not to go back to your
podcast where like you mention something
and all of a sudden you get like 20 ads
of it on your phone and you're like the
phone is listening it knows it is you're
watching ref for madness and then the
weed comes you're like the TV knows I
did this did this start with the driver
he said or did this start in the
restaurant that I ordered this from who
car who cares who cares just be happy
you got free weed thank you agreed or
give it back to the driver Columbus
Division of police spokesperson said
authorities are working to find out more
information from those who you're in a
college
town authorities authorities calls the
cops if you want the weed you smoke it
if you don't trust the weed you throw it
away and we should not know that this
happened at all not a problem if you're
in a college town like Columbus Ohio
yeah and you are calling the cops
because there's weed in your bag MH you
are one of the most insufferable people
in that col you hate the kids you hate
the school you hate the game day drop
part like you live here dude go music
too loud you know where the music's too
loud at the stadium I can hear it all
the way over here ex how I hope the cops
weren't taking this seriously I hope it
was just like yeah yeah hold on let me
let me talk to our best detective and
then just click and just I don't know
why if I were on the phone and the cop
who got this phone call I'd be like hey
can we uh pull those three people off
that murder that they're investigating
somebody got weed in their uh weeded got
weeded if if if it's a slow night at the
police
station how and if I was a cop just for
fun I would have I would bring full SWAT
oh to this surround his house with so
many cars door I kick the door down and
I'd like use the the metal that Rams it
in or I'd be like are you high right now
sir is this your weed no like well
that's what somebody who I would say
sound High bring I'm like do like the
weed pretty high do the weed test just
put a little piece of paper on his
tongue and like after that just be like
sir we just gave you LSD to make sure
that you weren counteract the
weed the man who received Lite at the
police station oh my God I just love to
just harass it like show up and like you
know run we're going to run some tests
just like pinch his nipples like and
he's like what what did you do what what
did I just do I didn't do anything
talking how are just getting readings on
the meter in the weird the man who
received the order said the driver left
then came back and asked for the bag of
marijuana he would give me my money back
and and refund my order if I gave him
the entire bag back cuz he claimed that
it was medicine in the bag for his
friend that was to be used for medical
reasons he said medical marijuana wait
wait are you saying medicine for medical
reasons which is how you know the driver
is lying he's just trying to get it back
but also give him his weed back why are
you calling this makes I hate this guy
more you're such a dick to like guy
comes goes hey man can I get the weed
back and he was like no he's like I'll
I'll refund the I'll tell him like it's
all free everyone hated this guy in high
school right I'll pay for your order
still my God like okay if you're this
guy and you got the weed and the guy hey
can I have my weed back I will pay for
your order yeah wouldn't you be like I
love this I got my food for free tonight
simple mistake what an amazing day
America what a country thank you right
but how high do you have to be to to put
your weed at the bottom of someone
else's order I don't know I've had times
where I've lost the parking ticket into
a garage and I don't know how between
getting it and getting out of my car I
don't know where this went where is so
he could have like oh let me throw my
like he didn't realize what bag he was
putting in in that's possible but either
way just give give this weed
back the man told the driver he could
not give him the bag back then he called
police and submitted a complaint to Door
Dash even if door Dash I'm like cool
click
ethically I I can't give you your drugs
I can't give you your hard drugs at door
Dash you call door Dash they're like
we're all high right now so send that
weed over here bro right uh a door Dash
representative called and emailed the
man to discuss the incident we do not
condone this type of action and
therefore have Tak was it let me know
removing the person from our platform so
now you got the guy fired oh my God the
email from the Dasher will no longer be
able to deliver future orders on door
Dash this is awful I hate this guy door
Dash well guess who's going to start
work for
GrubHub set ABC 6 fox28 this statement
what happened is not acceptable and we
have removed the Dasher from our
platform we appreciate the customer for
reporting the incident I don't
appreciate it that's just Optics yeah
but it's bad optics for that the the bag
we still hav we what if you're someone
who's high and orders door Dash all the
time I'd be like I'm not supporting door
Dash I'm to go Postmates cuz they don't
support the weed guy right right right
yeah that's true yeah it could be bad
it's like if you're in a comedy club and
people are talking and the club doesn't
do anything about it cuz they're like I
we don't want to throw that group out
what about the person who drove four
hours to see you and they're sitting
behind the person who's talking yep and
then the comics who don't want to come
back to your club because they don't
handle the room there are cons I didn't
think about it Dan here's a little
conspiracy for you in this this is what
the uh [__] who got the bag delivered
to him said it's scary because I'm a
healthcare worker which to me means he's
in filing that's right and I see how
this affects people every day we weed
the man who received the man who
received the delivery said I even have a
close friend I have a close friend whose
nephew I have a close friend whose
nephew actually passed away due to
smoking marijuana that was laced by
fentanyl F
Ked exactly first of all so fentol kill
F killed him you have a close friend
whose nephew no you read on Facebook
that's right and it's probably an urban
legend yeah you read it
who's who is putting fent on
weed they would have to dust it on there
to dust it and you'd be would do that
not any drug dealer that wants to make
money I'll tell you that no I mean they
mix it into heroin and Co like that
because a tiny bit goes a long way an
economic thing but only a like serial
killer is just Laing and not tell people
right right just for funsies like the
guy who killed MC Miller he he was
charged with murder because of the
amount like MC Miller was not trying to
kill himself he was not like and and
they and they also uh like the good
liars those dudes who do like all the
ttic TS they were talking to these
people that were like well they're
putting fentanyl on the kids candy and
they just broke they just kept asking
them questions they be like kids candy
drug dealers don't they tend to want to
sell drugs rather than just give it away
well they're putting it in that to kill
kids why would the drug dealers want to
kill kids have a trace back to that it's
I actually just researched that
Halloween urban urban legend there have
been no kids poisoned buy candy uh from
a stranger there was a there was a dad
in Texas who poisoned his own kids candy
cuz he was a maniac trying to like make
life insurance some horrible horrible
thing but the whole thing about like you
go to a stranger's house and you get
their poison candy nope nope never
happened anybody who has a friend's
nephew yeah is like is that you don't
know this person friend's nephew I would
start asking right away I'd be like
what's that nephew's name and how old
were they where did this happen these
kind of stories are why I Am So Pro drug
legalization like all of the drugs
because people are going to use them so
can you at least give them access to
clean drugs yep regulate them and have
them have them cuz there's a thing you
can test for like all this stuff and
make sure well there's a the Law and
Order taught me that there's a drug
overseas for people like trying to get
off math and everything it's like the
greatest drug ever but it it it can't
something about there's no patent on it
or whatever I don't know what it is
expired so it can't be no money can be
made off of it so they won't allow it in
United States because none of the
pharmacetical the pharmaceutical stuff
is it's so insane we're like well yeah
they made fentanyl fentanyl is a
synthetic drug like the whole heroin
epidemic it's like no it's not heroin
well I mean opioid but it's like it's
fentanyl you know most pooke over fenol
is what my wife got when she was
pregnant they gave her fentol when she
was yeah like to help her with the pain
you can't get stri sorry you can't get
strips just a PSA you can get them on
Amazon fentel test strips where if
you're going to do that stuff I was at a
Comedy Festival
fentol test trips that they just
gave because yes they gave them right
alongside kind bars because they knew so
many people were going to be doing coke
and stuff like that and it's a party
scene that they're like hey just test it
really quick my son's in college it's
like do I want him doing all of that
stuff no but I can't stop him so I'm
actually dropping off uh fentanyl test
strips for him I'm like going to show
him how to use them how how do you use a
fentanyl test I'm going to have to learn
cuz go I don't know I have the strips
but I have to watch the tutorial before
I explain it I don't even know I me you
test put a little bit on the weed I
think that's like the best thing right
with i i as a person who has no children
but like teaching your kid risk
assessments of like do the right things
I can't control what you're going to do
I'd like to influence how you evaluate
what you do yep if you give them lots of
responsibilities around a certain drug
that will turn them off from doing we'll
be right back with you'll be like this
how you well I also like I do stuff like
like whatever like and I don't hide it
from my kids and I've also told them I'm
like if you're going to do it if I can't
stop you please try it with me where at
least you're in a controlled environment
it's safe that also makes him not want
to do it because now rebelling against
oh exactly they're like dad my dad does
that lame well too bad for that too bad
for that friend's second cousin's
nephew's daughter oh God okay the man
who received the unwanted side of
marijuana said he's worried about what
could have happened if the order ended
up in the wrong hands what that could be
said of a fork that could be said of of
a car you know like anywhere
yeah I think about the kids I think
about the kids he said shut up I have a
nephew so now it's his nephew oh it your
I have a nephew you don't have kids okay
you have a NE no one wants to be your
partner to give this how bad he can't
even keep his story straight I think
about the kids he said I have a nephew I
think about my coworker he has
granddaughters and grandsons I thought
it was your co-workers no was your
Facebook friend's nephew who died passed
away of weed I literally want to hold
this guy down and force him to do
acid just dose him so hard right just be
like let's see what comes up man yeah
let's see what comes up I bet you're a
better person afterward or maybe we can
change your brain chemistry and you
won't do this
shitbin s goes yeah sbin micro dose him
for like a month and see if we can turn
him into a better person yeah we'll blow
some DMT in his
face now he's feeling hesitant about
ordering dinner to be delivered ever
again good good oh my God good I
I mean like what so when I hear a
statement like that like what do you
want door Dash to give you right CU
that's the type of stat mind confidence
I
know confidence he want he wants them to
come in like sit down with him during
the meal kind of rub his back you know
maybe take a bite first so we can wait
10 minutes see if that guy dies test Fel
test trip that's that's what food
testers were him in when the meal's over
tell him everything's going to be okay I
really feel like I question everything
now and I just want certain companies
like door Dash or GrubHub or others I
just want to question what kind of
background checks they're taking for
their shut up this guy's been talking
for too long I told you I hate thisy I
hate him is he trying to like get a
lawsuit going like for emotional try to
run for I don't even think it's that I
don't even think it's that calculated
yeah I think he's just a loser I think
he's so I think he's one of those people
who doesn't know if what he did or The
Stance he took was right and so he just
keeps trying to make this case to
himself but out to the public or he has
a total blind spot when it comes to
other people's reactions to his behavior
right it's like I just was trying to I'm
doing the right thing it's like no the
right thing is not the right thing for
the situation like you got to read the
room there's so like I feel like fewer
people know how to read the room right
and for anybody who's like there could
have been fentanyl in there I go well
yeah also it could have been that that
door Dash driver uh is a Vietnam non
veteran that uses that weed for his
post-traumatic stress disorder so as as
much as you would like to believe in one
you have to equally believe in the other
if we're just going down any possibility
he's not getting paid enough that he's
got to sell this weed as another way to
supplement his income to people who need
it because yes he has
arthritis you want to go down right and
all the guy ever had to do was just give
the guy his feedback N I hope this guy
works with at least one person who just
on a regular basis like hey Todd hey
Todd shut the [__] up and then just like
walks off just like it's L just shutting
him down did you get that menu that memo
about you shutting the [__] up exactly
you want me to resend it I'll put it to
the top of your chain so that let me
move it up so he questions everything he
wants to know what kind of checks
they're doing and do they really know
the people who are working for them
because I mean clearly this one fell
through the cracks okay fell through the
crack according to Door Dash's website
the company runs motor vehicle and
criminal background checks on all its
drivers great that's it police said this
is the first time they've heard of drugs
being delivered in a bag of delivered
food well that's you guys are idiots too
because this happens all the time all
the time
yeah one down the books Dan cumins is
with us we'll uh when we come back we're
going to talk about uh your special
you're going to talk about uh your
podcast time suck which is awesome and
uh we'll let people know uh Dan you want
to go first yeah we'll let you know what
you have going on uh there dumb people
tell with Dan cumins we'll be right
back hey guys welcome back to the show
before we get into all the stuff that
Dan cumins has going on Daniel let us
know what uh what's cooking with you
movie wine club uh it's my movie I'm the
lead I'm so glad to have been a part of
it and get to talk about it now you
should go and check it out uh Steve
little for me spaed down is one of my
co-stars and Taylor Ortega uh plays my
wife she is it's as much uh her movie as
it is mine she's she's amazing so check
that movie out um I think the release
date if it hasn't been announced yet
it'll be announced soon wine club movie
on Instagram great uh go to Daniel
vk.com I'll be at Cap City comedy club
on December 14th if this is around that
otherwise I have more dates for the rose
gold tour coming out um soon leading up
to the release of special which you just
shot in Chicago which is awesome I'm so
psyched for you uh Dan cumins you have a
podcast called time suck which is
amazing if you like this I feel like you
do kind of explore and I'm sure much
more as we kind of went into at the very
beginning explore and debunk conspiracy
theories with a humorous with comedy I
mean I just try to apply like critical
thinking and just a a sense of
reasonableness to whatever topic I'm
exploring and so there's a lot of
reactionary statements of like why would
you ever do this what is happening here
yeah which and then the flip side is
that now we live in a time where you
just using reason to debunk these things
elicits a reaction from a certain group
of people who are like why would you do
this right why would you try and
yourself who Dan cumins is really being
paid oh my God we I get that you get
that a lot also isn't a lot of
conspiracy there is a a part of just
tribe mentality because once you say you
believe a thing some other group beli
they're so welcoming to bring you into
the fold that people really find their
tribe under this false pretense because
once you just say oh I think that too
instantly that the welcomeness and the
and the the camaraderie or the
fellowship between those people becomes
as uh as if not more important than
whatever it is they've said they believe
in right and it gives people a a
boogeyman to blame for all their
problems which is the the appeal of that
tribe where it's like it's not it's not
my fault it's not a uh some negative
character traits or a lack of hustle
that has me in this space where I'm at
in life and not where I want to be it's
because of the Illuminati it's because
of these evil forces that are you know
conspiring against me you know what's so
sad actually on that 90% of all
conspiracies are anti-semitic I swear to
God they go back to the protocols the of
the of Zion which was Russian propaganda
which is meeting notes and quotes for
meetings that never happened and it's
like the way these modern conspiracies
are they their sources are just older
piles of [__] just nonsense that's right
and it's like it it just goes back and
back and it's really frustrating really
frustrating that it's like and a lot of
people don't even see that so I love
that you're doing this because when you
started doing this podcast it and it
became extraordinarily popular it was
just a fascinating thing to know that
these conspiracy theories existed the
crazy thing about it like a marriage or
anything it has grown it's evolved
conspires conspiracies have come to the
mainstream so I think your podcast is
more important than ever to listen to
you know it's like and we do you know
True Crime and other things true but but
I hit that same message that I do with
the conspiracies and it's funny it's
like I started getting kind of depressed
about I don't know a year ago where I
was like I should just give up like like
it's this is pointless I'm just yelling
to the void but then it's like you're
right it is more important now because
if there aren't more people debunking
these things it's just going to get
worse confront with the truth I love it
and and do it in a funny way which
you're a funny guy so and that's where I
I I got a little off of the path for a
while there because it made me so angry
that I started getting more heavy-handed
with my delivery and I'm like nope that
just pushes people away the people who
are really gone we're not going to get
them back but there are those people in
the middle that I have gotten emails
where it's like you know one guy
actually uh came to this little summer
camp we had and he was like thanked me
he was like I was full in on that kind
of stuff and a friend recommended one of
your podcasts wow and I started to feel
a little silly and I started to look at
in a different and he did pull out of it
I'm like stuff inspiring you save one
person you better the world yeah yeah
and it's like and and I don't want to
see our you know culture just collapse I
mean it does truly scare me that we have
people in major political offices who I
mean I don't think they believe it often
times I think they power it's a power
grab access audience yeah that's almost
worse it it is it's talk about how dark
well you saw I mean you saw in a lot of
and I don't want to get political get
political you did see in a lot of people
who who were like on air personalities
pushing one narrative off air being like
I don't believe this [__] you're like no
you're you're you're causing worse
you're you're digging people deeper into
those people buy buy T-shirts they they
tune in it's like they know they know
what and they need it more than let's
talk about your special too you have a
new standal so let's hear it let's tell
people about it where they can get it
all that stuff yeah it's just uh just
did a YouTube release um filmed it at
the Parkway Theater in Minneapolis
awesome so fun and and they redid it for
the shoot you know I guess we did um so
it looks really cool and beautiful
theater yeah it is it it's super fun I
had done that like 10,000 laughs Comedy
Festival a few years before yeah I just
did it did a show so fun and did a show
there and I was like oh this is a really
it's intimate but it's still uh
Tech yeah it's a small theater and it
just has a really good Acoustics and it
was so fun it was so fun great did all
your people come out I mean yeah yeah
yeah so the podcast crowd came out it
was funny um you know I I make fun of
the left and the right for like the
first half an hour especially then I
just kind of get into weird random
stories yeah and I had just been in
Austin actually uh the same club that
you're coming up at Cap City the the
week before or two weeks before and it
was funny where the jokes that skewered
the right got you know a little more
subdued response in Austin and the jokes
that skewered the left huge rockus exact
opposite of Minneapolis
it yeah if you can I mean they still
laughed at both but it was funny just
the premises were like oh this is my
ideology yeah that's so funny he's
talking about me I don't know if I like
this yet that's right me shall I jump
into another story okay this one is sent
in by J Chris Mueller at J Chris Mueller
I think this is a new person
I love go to Daniel vankar Brothers on X
or Twitter whatever you call it and #
Dum people town we'll know when you send
J Chris Mueller sounds like a bar that
you drink at before the Cardinal games
in St Louis it's like it's like next to
cardwells I'm not going go to cardwells
I'm going to J they have better steak
bites good good you ready for this this
is just so fun it's just a fun story
driver tried to switch places with his
dog on I stop in Colorado Town Police a
come here rusty you get he tried to
switch place a for creativity thank you
right
right I
do you guys are never going to believe
this sh he's all over the place he's
also it changes old perspective right
you're like he's pretty good isn't he I
mean not perfect I get why he pull over
but he's pretty good two and a half but
that's 18 in dog years so he's of age
all right so I'm not going to tell you
all the driver is we'll get to that
later okay Springfield Colorado a driver
found himself in the
dogghouse is this the New York Post for
God's sakes after he attempted to switch
places with his pup when he got pulled
over on suspicion of dii on Saturday
night like Freaky Friday or you just
being physic jump into my soul I know
well that the The Shaggy DA that was the
guy who turned into a dog this is Shaggy
DA come to life he's really The District
Attorney Springfield police chief clay
clipfell no clay clipfell CL a y k i PF
clay cell clay clip clipfell that's a
tough one to say backup quarterback for
the Kansas City Chiefs conducted a
traffic stop on a driver who was going
you want you want to know what he was
doing to like how fast he was going yeah
fast he was going in what zone so how
fast his speed what's the zone I'm not
going to tell you this tell us the Z
tell the Zone Zone's 30 minut 30 m hour
Zone how fast was he Going's like some
neighborhood or something yeah 30 is
like scho 46 M hour 46 what do you think
70 think Dan I'll say 50 I feel like I
just pric it
righted all right here you go uh he was
going 52 in a 30
Zone com all right uh at about what time
let's let's do this now what time did
the did the cops pull him over when
would you want your dog to drive right
after you took him for a good walk I'm
going to say like ran like really early
weird like 2: p.m. 2 p.m. what do you
think Jay 6 p.m. 6 p.m. Dan Dan I'm
going to go 11:30 p.m. okay one of you
is exactly right no [__] one of you
exactly stay with me I said Dan you're
going to switch to Dan if I had to pick
who you can switch you can switch I
don't know dog does feel daytime to me
now I'm doing it 6 p.m. I'm staying at
what did you say Dan I said 2 p.m. I'm
going to go two I'm going to go okay so
flip-flopped we did this last time but
we were both wrong in the last one we
did okay get your answers in townies
because he was pulled over doing 52 in a
30 m per hour Zone yeah at 11:30
p.m. either way either way a Dan was
right a Dan was right okay so near West
7th Avenue and Main Street in the town
of Springfield according to police which
by the way we should mention we just
came back from Springfield uh Missour
where we did the Blue Room have you ever
done the Blue Room unbelievable room
unbelievable Town such nice owners of
that club Chris and Molly are the
coolest Daniel you should be doing this
amazing and we'll be back every year to
the people at Springfield who came out
to see us driver attempted to switch
places with his dog which was in the
passenger seat of a Dodge Challenger
that was a challenge of what he tried to
do a process he wrote that a a process
that clip Phil watched as he walked
towards the car oh so he wasn't even no
you get put the seat belt on I want you
get a ticket for not wearing a seat belt
you know he climbed in the back probably
put your paws on the wheel put your paws
on theel thing is is the clipfell
officer clipfell watched the whole you
can't do it in front of the cops so the
suspect we had clear signs of
intoxication you know in his brain he
was like we're going I'm going to make
this happen right here check bait got
out of the passenger side of the car and
told the chief that he wasn't the one
driving I was I tried to stop him I you
know thank you so much officer he was
not listening I was too drk I made the
right decision he put weed in his gains
Burgers I don't think he wants to be
here when clipfell asked whether we'd
been drinking are we all picturing a lab
oh yeah I was trying to think for some
reason I had a retriever stuck in my
head yeah like that what it no it's not
like a collie no it need to be big
enough to like mimic the act of driving
it's like a brown lamb remember we did
the story with Kyle Canan where um there
was a man who was dressed as dog made
himself look like like a dog oh yeah he
was a kie he was it a colie or like a
lassie do oh he like a lassie dog and it
looked exactly like a dog so you could
say this is my friend this is this is
Gordon I would love it if it was like a
little Boston Terrier like a tiny little
dog they can't even barely on the bottom
of the like a
corgi corg has to stretch to reach the
bottom we can't see you just see like a
little I'm going to say this next sends
and you'll be like this is the greatest
reaction to a question ever and when
this happened clipfell when clipfell
asked whether the man had been drinking
the man tried to run
away serve you been drinking I'll take
that as a yes I love like plan a is see
if I can convince him the dog was
driving just go just go suspect's
getaway attempt was cut short after how
many yards from the car that's I mean
this is short right yeah I don't know I
10 10 yards what do you think no more
than 10 yards 40 okay three
yards about 10t how far does the taser
reach right get your get your answers in
to cuz he fell and he fell
twice some point the officer was like
I'm just going to see how far he gets
okay so the car's the dog's in the front
seat and he runs away when he asks him
have you been drinking sir after he told
him that the dog was driving his
flip-flop broke 20 yards from the
car okay farther than I would yeah when
has aand and a woman were sober and they
were in the back seat of the car oh my
God how weird for that why didn't you
try and switch with another person exact
why is a drunk guy and a dog in the
front and then two sober people those
are the dumbest people of
this whole story I would love if it's an
Uber if you're sober you're like dude
let me drive you can't drive what are
the wild the sober people are the
dumbest people in I would agree 100% you
know it's also it's a twood door car
unless they called this guy and said and
he's their Uber yeah that's what he was
saying that's right okay a man and woman
so in the back seat police say they were
later found found out the trio were
driving from Las Animas to Pueblo and
got lost in Springfield which is all
right so for the record Springfield is
southeast of Los Animas while peblo is
to the West the drivers later found to
have two active warrants out in peblo
according to Springfield police he was
medically cleared at a hospital and then
booked into the Baka County jail for his
warrants and on suspicion of driving
Under the Influence driving while
ability impaired driving under
suspension speeding and resisting arrest
and throwing his dog under the bus thr
his dog under the bus I agre as to the
dog the other two occupants of the
vehicle took the pup along with the
vehicle back to peblo there you go and
and neutered him that night I wanted to
imagine the story ends with the dog
driving the couple home the dog drove
the couple home while they were
having dogs like what do he say he's
like he said he's taking it some that's
the dumbest part of that story is two
sober people in the back I mean there's
so many dumb parts of that story he's
like where you drinking sir runs away
move the dog in there then where you
drinking runs away and then there's two
sober people in the back seat all right
Jay give us a little taste what we're
going to get for Segment you got uh
somebody pretending to be a cop and it
doesn't work out n at least he wasn't
pretend to be a dog this is Dum people
Town Dan cumins is with us we'll tell
you what we have going on on the other
side this break around
s hey guys we know the holidays are
crazy if you're like us it's crazy
whatever holidays you celebrate this
time of year is nuts you don't have time
to sit around and cook meals and whatnot
you need to still eat nutritiously you
need to still eat normal things you
can't just subsist on a whole handful of
chocolate popcorn why we're glad there's
Factor B thank God for Factor because
they look you you skip the extra trip to
the grocery store and The Chopping and
prepping and the cleanup too all still
while getting flavor and a nutritional
quality that you need factors fresh
never frozen meals are ready in 2
minutes so all you have to do is heat
and enjoy and those meals they're so
tasty they are so good sustainable
premium ingredients it's just great
stuff yeah yeah you know I so I've been
using factor for a long time and I'm
going to tell you right now it is some
of the food is better than it should be
like I look forward to eating the queso
Fondo like you just don't think it's
going to be like like you're like oh man
this was sent to me no it's such great
quality meals and quality ingredients
and sent to you in a way that everything
still tastes fresh everything that's
chicken I absolutely love the pesto
salmon AB that so good I've done the
shakes and they're great too I've done
the uh some of the breakfast bites those
are wonderful as well unev yeah and and
and really honestly be able to like
reach into you're like at the beginning
of day if you're heading off to the work
you're leaving for the day like I
usually am and you can grab two of your
meals and then just throw them in the
fridge and heat them up later when you
get to the office it's it's Absol how
many times we forget to eat in a day me
a lot but not when I have Factor so guys
you can head to factor meals.com dp50
and use the code dp50 to get 50% off
that's code dp50 at factor meals.com
dp50 to get 50% off all right guys I
want to talk to you about a brand new
product that that are friends at
Skylight remember the Skylight frame
which is the best gift we've ever given
to those are still around but I want to
talk about the Skylight calendar this is
such a great idea because you know I'm
in in my family everybody's doing
something in the opposite direction I
can't tell you how many times I'm like I
have to go do a show tonight my wife's
like wait what put put it down I'm like
put it down where well guess what we
have the place for you to put it down
it's the Skylight calendar it's so cool
I love this Skylight calendar is a smart
touchscreen calendar and organizer for
all your chores groceries and to-dos it
automatically syncs listen to this all
of the different digital calendars and
events your family uses and shows them
all together in one beautiful
touchscreen display this is like a
personal assistant for you right there
Skylight calendar is the best way to
give your family a peace of mind and
peace of mind and enjoy the things that
matter most so you know when everything
is happening this is the perfect holiday
Sky calendar is super easy to set up and
use it works by sinking the events from
already existing calendars like Randy
you said that you have including your
Google your outlook your Apple calendars
you can also add events directly using
the touchcreen or with the free Skylight
mobile app it shows all the family
events together in one spot so you can
see what everyone has going on each week
they are colorcoded so you can visually
map out your family's plans into a
beautiful color coded time block it just
makes everything really easy you can
even do like household tests with a
chore chart feature guys it's it's
wonderful I have one sent to me in my
life I put it right into the uh like the
production office that I used
because have
have I need so I SN everything up that I
need to together I also have personal
deadlines of things we write and stuff
that we want to do I love it and to me
just such a visual learner and and and I
hold on to things visually that I see
and kind of can interact with it just
makes it so much better than just having
in my phone so guys as a special limited
offer to our listeners you can get $15
off your purchase of a skylight calendar
when you go to Skylight cal.com DPT to
get $15 off your purchase of a sky
Skylight calendar just go to Skylight
cal.com DBT that's SK y l i g
htc.com
DPT guys step into a world of non-stop
action on DraftKings Casino play the
classics like Blackjack roulette and
Slots plus enjoy exclusive games you
cannot find anywhere else all you have
to do is sign up select the offer make
your deposit and start playing from a
full Suite of games I love gambling I
like going and playing I like playing
roulette I like playing slot machines so
that's why for me this is so much fun
because you can play anywhere they have
hundreds of variations on casino games
you'll find anything that fits your
taste on DraftKings casino app there's
low minimums you can play as low as high
stakes as you feel but you know what
else is great which I love you you don't
have to play for real money you're not
ready to play for real money it's not a
problem all DraftKings games let you
test out the games for free to let you
find sometimes I'm just jonesing for
that Blackjack and I don't want fun yeah
yeah just for a little fun it's a great
idea so here's we've been doing
DraftKings and fantasy stuff on
DraftKings for years and years and I was
thinking to myself when are they going
to get into this space and they've come
into this space in such a great way so
tell them what to do Dan guys download
the DraftKings casino app now and sign
up with the promo code DPT new customers
can get a deposit match of up to $500 in
Casino credits when you deposit $5 or
more more only on DraftKings casino with
promo code DPT gambling problem call 1
1800 Gambler or visit www.1 1800 gambler
net in Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 8887895118
terms and responsible gambling gaming
[Music]
resources hey gang welcome back to the
show townies we love you thank you for
supporting us always by uh with the
patreon Jay and I have a patreon that uh
we do cheap seats episodes on so check
that out got a lot of dates coming up
like basically one weekend out of every
month we're going to be on the road and
doing really fun stuff um we are going
to be Cleveland Ohio December first and
second which I can't wait to do those
shows those are going to be really fun
uh and David Rodriguez from the comedy
Ford have you ever done the comedy Fort
oh God you should do that another one
you guys another one in Fort Collins
he's going to be uh with us that weekend
with us and featuring for us that
weekend and then we'll be in Portland at
Helium beginning of January and then the
crocodile the next night on the 5th
fourth and fth fourth and fifth and then
we'll be in back in Denver at the comedy
work South Club which I really love
first weekend of February first weekend
of February and then the first weekend
in March will be in uh Mark Ridley's
Comedy Castle in Detroit and then we'll
be in Minneapolis the beginning of April
and then Moon toow so
supercars.net around the country and you
meet you meet all kinds of people owners
who are really want to just do their
business owners who want their business
to go up their nose in the form of
cocaine owners who really love comedy
owners who freak you out about how much
they love comedy but really the people
who are good to The Comedians and care
about their business at the same time
they're loved by the community what Nick
did to hilarities in that area in
downtown Cleveland he saved downtown
Cleveland saved he was the first the F
pck and Frolic was the first business in
downtown Cleveland again being in
Springfield Missouri
the blue room they have like established
something there that is like incredible
and beautiful Chris and Molly that like
it's they're helping bring all these
great people there's a Comedy Works what
Wendy did in Comedy Works is like change
Denver as a city like Comics come people
come to Denver for comedy like that's
insane yeah they've created a whole
comedy so support us on the road sus.com
get your tickets here this is from Matt
Freedman not your average Matt he's a
good contributor thank you Budd uh
Barber accused of posing as officer to
see Megan the stallion at final four
Fest by the way it's Megan the stallion
the St so let's not post not get it
twisted Jay post a certain level bond
which we will guess later I want him to
be dressed up as a like you guys said
earlier like a like a canine cop like a
dog
cop previous story he's MCU he's McGruff
m m Gruff the crime dog dog in a trench
coat take a bite out of crime uh the
sound effect of the bite in that
commercial is kind of amazing it's an
amazing sound effect it's a good get it
up get it up and we'll play it on the
microphone all right uh Houston Texas
Dan spends a lot of time at with buddies
at the secret group secret group You'
been there right fantastic my God Andrew
Young Blood oh
yeah featur theater he was there with my
special with me I love Andrew solid
people all right a man accused her
pretending to be a police officer to
sneak into Friday's final four FanFest
concert this obviously the Final Four F
so at part of the final four weekend
first weekend of April you can kind of
see where we are in terms of stories in
terms of the my schedule on the story on
the story timeline uh they have a big
concert that you can go to and this guy
you know you know how I'm going to the
concert you going to buy a ticket not
that idea no I'm going to pretend to be
a love got the CRI oh my God I yes his
stories are wild oh he's he's like the
crime DOD they make me anxious family
and your community safe and help uh take
a bite out of crime
it's just celery right just breaking
celery I don't know what it is take a
bite out a crime take a bite out a crime
so uh Megan the East stallion headlined
uh he faced a judge on Monday to uh
Trayvon larus Stevenson his middle name
is Lil darus Lil darus okay I mean I
wouldn't have bought it if it was just
regular darus how old do you think this
cat is trayon little darus L darus about
trayon trayon lus Esquire the
third really wants to see Megan the
stallion dresses up as a cop to do it
Trayvon L Stevenson I mean I think he'd
get farther if he just said I'm a great
Barber and people be like get in here
why I just dress up as like an employee
who like sells Coca-Cola at RIS just go
get a red Polo and black slack Man part
of the concessions yeah I'm late for my
shift right there how old 25 yeah I like
that I mean Cash go talk to cash Levy
he's like broken into yeah so many Super
Bowls I say he's 29 years old cuz I
don't think Megan the
stallion oh man I'm going to go earlier
what did you say 25 I'm going to say 19
whoa yeah by the way I'm hoping he's 60
I'm saying 25 I'm hoping do I mean that
case you just let him go let him have
sex with Megan the 35 years old 35 years
old all right this man who 19352 Trayvon
L darus Stevenson 28 years old okay
there you go his Saturn is returning um
he was held in Harris County Jail over
the weekend after being charged with
impersonating a public servant you
cannot do that can't do it crime all the
things just like don't cop is the worst
you can pretend to be in terms of what
you're going to get charged with cop is
the thing that they can punish you so
you're going you're going to love this
you're going to love this right cuz
otherwise it would just be trespassing
right right you just you just trespass
in a weird way also like if you tried to
be a baker to get in there that's I'm
saying I love that just a a ridiculous
costume that doesn't fit really high
really high Pillsbury doughy if you
rolled up to any person getting paid
[__] $11 an hour to barcode scan and
you're in a fullon crazy like like a
muppet Chef's costume and you were like
I work I'm I have to work the The
Carving Station they'd be like station
so you have like I don't know why we
always dress The Carving Station people
up like this really tall hat they would
let you in why why is the hat so tall at
a Carving Station do they think that
like for somehow some way if it's not
that tall like people have carved it and
Dan you've seen the Dan and Daniel you
you guys I'm guessing you've seen that
like video from like the training video
for like how to talk to peopley the the
guy at the caring station of a thing
he's like and it's just him saying a
bunch of conversation starters for The
Carving Station weird weather nice
weather we're having huh is it satirical
or real
was real was told from a training video
of how these employees should like start
conversations at the car how's the
weather you have to teach someone as
he's carving that's an interesting dress
it's been too long since I was at a
Carving Station I I always feel like I'm
having a pretty damn great if I've ended
up at a Carving Station didn't I have a
carving something at at Le's bar at my
son's Bar Mitzvah I don't no we had
other
station Carving Station at home that be
yeah who's that that's our carving go
over and he he'll cut you
some if you want to have a private
conversation and you're somewhere like
meet me at The Carving
Station got some information I want so
in front of this guy court documents
read that stepen allegedly wore a police
can9
vest trying to be
the he want to be part of the canine
unit I would love if he brought a German
Shepherd too like really committed like
okay so if he did and said to people
don't pet him he he's working he's on
the clock he's working please so he
claim he claimed to be working security
as a police officer in his mind Daniel
he he thinks this is going to work
there's no way this doesn't I'm going to
walk right up there I have the best with
the intention of seeing Megan the
stallion sold do performance you have to
have a dog though that if you have the
dog they probably weird to have that
outfit of not a dog true that's your
first red flag uh attorney said
Stevenson is actually a barber in
Houston and has no qualifications as any
type of officer have showed up as the
barber as the barber and people been
like get him in although he was wearing
a police canine vest he reportedly did
not have a dog with
him first rule of police canine dog
impersonation you got to have a dog I'm
I'm picturing like a like a weird
weekend at Bernie type like he has like
a like a stuffed animal or something
like like maybe stuck to a skateboard or
something that he's just like pulling
down next to him you've seen those
haven't you like the guy's got like a
giant stuffed animal dog and he's
walking and he just walks by someone
he's like and the person's like Yay
people lose their mind lose their mind
appropriately so it's crazy that gu not
expecting it it will freak but but he
could he also have said my dog's in
there I need to get my dog oh maybe my
dog they someone took my dog my dog we
have a real we have a real situation we
real we have a real situation is a great
way to come we have a real just we have
a real situation so they're like sir
what are you doing we have a real
situation situation my them off yeah we
yeah you to stand down my dog is in
there and I need to go in and get him
time is of the essence time is of the
essence is another great phrase to like
guys we're losing seconds here if we're
arguing if we're going to sit around and
debate this the Situation's only going
to get worse you're on you're on a need
to know you're need to know basis and
right now you need to know that I need
to be in there uh just throwing out
these random like quot it's above your
pay grade i' love P grade hey it's above
my pay grade I got to get in there we're
losing light on this one I got to my my
hands are tied on this right right you
think I want to be
here Dan that's such a good thing to say
for a guy trying to sneak into a
concert I just want to get home to my
wife I don't know what let me just do
this so I can get out of here let me
just do this so I can get out of here
and go home I got a boss just like you
I'm not trying to ruffle any feathers
right and also make them go make them go
with you I'm actually going to need you
to come with me I I really can't be like
okay well okay fine well then I'll be
right back boom see at the end of the
concert I'll leave you my walkie-talkie
so you know I'm coming back leave walkie
uh all right on Monday the judge granted
Stevenson who has no previous record so
that's what we're dealing with here
someone who who is not there's some
people who can pull this stuff off
because they just know how to pull these
things off because they do it all the
time this is a first foray into this
world he watched a movie or something
and then it's like I can do that or got
inspired by how am I going to get in
there I'm going to the mean d stying
concert how much was the bond for this
guy 1,500
5K uh 800 bucks you're going to lose
your minds when you find out that it's a
$20,000 what it's serious oh foran
officer yeah person an officer court
record shows Stevenson bonded out after
his
hearing Megan The Styling is a fantastic
draw Big Draw especially here in Houston
but this is still a felony case yes you
can't do it you cannot go and
impersonate an officer to get into a
concert venue prosecutor Matthew Jackson
told Eyewitness News at Monday he the
other problem about doing that too is
like what if someone really needed help
right like you don't want the respons
like that's where it can get really bad
you know what I'm saying like if he's in
there something happens yes offer fake
cop Reas not a movie fake cops Oh Let's
be cops cops that's another reason you
don't want to be a cop you don't want
the responsibility either
like he actually gets in he's like so
over his head then a fight breaks out
and then he has to stay in character and
now he handcuffs somebody and then he's
like I have no idea stay quiet he just
walks him into the bathroom and then
just maybe puts him in a stall like just
stay here for a little while about what
you did think about what you did stay
here until after the oncore this is your
Miranda Lambert right he has no idea
Miranda I'm going to read you your I'm
going to read you your Lambert rights
what the Miranda Lambert is that it oh
God that's it that's the story craziness
I love what a great this is such a fun
episode guy it's just a guy trying to
get a dog and to be The Driver a guy
trying to personated everybody's trying
to do something else perfect for Dan
cumins again his podcast is time suck
the name of the specialist so people
could get it and watch it was trying to
get better trying to get get better Dan
cumins trying to get better watch the
special tell people about it give it a
good review that's always good on on
YouTube right and yes in the comment
section I it is pretty funny just just
go for the comment section alone it's
utter nonsense I just encouraged uh
podcast fans to leave random lines from
the time Su from time suck episodes yeah
so there a lot of talk about like you
know me ruining the Library of
Alexandria we should all be able to shbs
like it's complete what a great and I
love that your fans came back for you
and and did that for you again uh trying
to get better Dan cumins we love you
guys we'll see you on the road and oh
[__] we got to get back to
[Music]
work